jetzt schlage ich mal mit der schere auf
dieses jahr auf dieses pferd drauf ich
habe jetzt vier schläge dafür gebraucht
juli so mache ich eigentlich immer diese
bewegung das ist total spaß tisch ich
glaube wenn ihnen wenn ich das erst mal
sieht und er denke ich wird das ist so
wie wenn dumbledore so seinen gedanken
in harry potter aus seinen gedanken
mit dieser kleinen exkursionen in die
tiefen welten der harry potter
mythologie ich finde er ist ein mega
geil wäre egal wir befinden uns hier bei
dem minecraft fact und da möchte ich
herzlich willkommen heißen ich habe mir
wieder fünf effekt rausgesucht die mir
unter anderem zu gesendet wurden die ich
im forum von hab ich im krieg gefunden
habe die ich selber rausgefunden hat und
so weiter und ich glaube ihr werdet ihr
schon schwindlig also ich würd mich
freuen
der erste weg wurde mir von einer
periode
ich möchte am leben bleiben bot mitte zu
gewinnen wenn man sagt ich möchte anonym
bleiben ist es eigentlich immer so dass
man gesagt bekommt der wolke cloud von
eben vorher unter dem den habe ich mir
nicht ganz selber ausgedacht allerdings
glaube ich dieser person einfach mal ein
mädchen
zwar hüpfe ich hier schon rum wie sonne
behinderte aber ich nehme einfach mal
ein kessel stelle an kessel intakter
wasser rein und dann haben wir hier
einen kessel mit wasser drin allerdings
der effekt kümmert sich um eine andere
sache und zwar ihr ich hab's euch
letzten schon mal angezeigt werde ich
damit feuer reingehen oder so wenn ich
brenne
dann werde ich hier inhalt gelöscht und
so weiter ich kann den kessel reingehen
ich hatte auch schon mal sex glaube ich
wohnen wohnen kessel mit den pisten
weggedrückt wurden dann backt man aus
der seite des kessels raus ich hatte
schon alle möglichen sachen und das ist
wirklich echt nur unnötiges wissen in
minecraft aber ich möchte euch einfach
zeigen wenn ich diesen kessel abbau das
wasser drin deswegen bin ich extra in
den games 0 begangen dann kommen die
ritze ebenfalls hier auf dem wasser also
als wenn man das wasser mit abbauen
würde und nicht nur am rand des kessels
sondern es wird quasi mit dem wasser
zusammen als block angesehen wenn ich
das hier mal rausnehmen oder so seien
bisher nur hallo hallo hallo hallo
wasser was okay ich hab mir grad so was
tolles aufgebaut das ich mich eben daran
verbrennen hallo du sollst dir wirklich
so jetzt brenne ich jetzt kann ich ja
beispielsweise mal reingehen löschen
mich hiermit und auch wenn ich jetzt
drauf gehe die die schon da ich ein
richter auf bei dem check wasser sodass
es egal wie hoch das wasser da drin
steht ihr seht der riss geht dann
dementsprechend auch weiter runter auf
das was da drauf und das wasser wird mit
als block angesehen und nicht als
irgendeine substanz die ich quasi
einfach darauf gestellt hat sondern die
risse kommen wirklich auf das was damit
drauf obwohl man eigentlich nur den
kessel an bord allerdings ist das
deswegen weil das wasser jetzt ja nicht
irgendwie wegläuft sondern also nicht
irgendwie jetzt gedroppt wird oder
irgendwo sondern ist quasi mit zu den
block zu also wenn ich den kästen abbau
ist das wasser direkt auch mit weg das
denkt weiß quasi jeder eigentlich und
das wegenetz auf perfekten ranger dann
kann dich anonyme person die nicht
gültig nummer zwei ist mir selber
aufgefallen und zwar habe ich einfach
mal geschaut
ok damals war es nämlich so dass man
ganz ganz viel power mit dem bogen
braucht um boot ab so schießt
mittlerweile kann ich schon sonnen obst
sitze ich im büro weile kann ich schon
einfach so ein bisschen schießen und das
boot schon direkt weg allerdings was mir
aufgefallen ist wenn ich so ein bisschen
schief achtet man auf das boot das hat
nur ganz wenig gewackelt wenn ich
allerdings viel mehr schießt also wenn
ich beispielsweise mal soviel schieße
dann wackelt das boot vielmehr wenn es
diesmal genau das gleiche auch hier
beispielsweise bei einer lore wenn ich
da mal ganz toll drauf schieße seht ihr
schon die wackelt extrem viel dreht sich
quasi fast einmal im kreis und wenn ich
relativ wenig drauf schieße wackelt die
nutzer ein bisschen ich zeige euch das
noch mal an das logo schon jetzt mal
eben hier ist die laureate schließlich
auf die
drauf und jetzt zügig die lore da drauf
und dann steht man nur ganz klein
bisschen denke dass man das in der slow
motion gerade ganz gut gesehen hat dass
das wirklich extrem krass verändert wie
sehr dieser block diesmal also er dies
bei uns so oder so dieses dieses diese
logo bzw
das boot allerdings wackelt es mehr wenn
ich mit mehr power darauf schießen bei
einem rüstung ständer oder einen anderen
entity ist es natürlich so dass es quasi
einfach wirklich weg geht einfach dies
bond aber hier bei diesen sachen wo ich
wirklich somit interagieren kann und
wirklich es mich zur einsetzen kann man
alles mögliche da ist es halt schon
krass am wackeln wenn ich desto doller
ich drauf schieße so und das ist eine
sache die mir selber aufgefallen dass
freunde die dritte sache ist ein fakt
der mir bei instagram zu gesendet wurde
und zwar meinte dort eine seite meinte
da ja hier guck mal hier wir haben die
besten minecraft hat das untere bild
gepostet wo ich mit mit simon und max
und palle und justin im youtube hausbau
oder das wäre also dass es werbung das
hat man mir nichts zu tun wenn dann
trotzdem ob dieser draufgegangen
da war allerdings eine sache die ich das
interessant fand und ganz simpel und ich
denke dass wir noch einigen leuten
weiterhelfen und zwar ihr kennt ja immer
diese tank zu manchmal hat man ja echt
lang fehler 100 oder denkt man sich um
liegt das jetzt daran dass meine welt
kaputt ist oder ist das einfach nur
nicht geladen wird man kann ganz einfach
gucken ob man in dem tank ist in dem man
einfach die iks oder z koordinate also
das ist ja xyz und die iks koordinaten
317 dz koordinate 71 und eine von den
beiden koordinaten oder beide müssen
durch 16 teilbar sein das heißt jetzt
einfach mal die die z koordinate wenn
ich jetzt nicht beispielsweise einfach
mal zu 16 hinfliegen also genau hier bin
ich auf koordinate 16 dann kann ich
davon ausgehen moment warte ich könnte
eigentlich die iks koordinate 1660 320
könnte ich einfach mal zu 320 gehen das
heißt genau hier bei 16 und 320 ist es
quasi ganz so dass hier irgendwie sonn
chan grenze ist entweder ist die
schamgrenze hier oder hier ist ein
schrank oder hier ist neuer tank oder
hier ist deutschland eigentlich ist hier
sogar überall neuer tank war das ist
hier auf jeden fall so die grenze
zwischen diese könnt diese gabelung
zwischen diese chance ist und wenn hier
jetzt beispielsweise hier 16 16 blöcke
nicht laden könnt ihr auf jeden fall
davon ausgehen dass ein krankes tier
einfach fehlt allerdings
nun ja wenn dann halt wenn ich nicht
durch 16 teil bestand ist es auf jeden
fall keinen schrank und dann ist einfach
eure welt kaputt
das ist einfach eine ganz simple sache
womit man sich das merken kann einfach
wenn die dx oder z koordinate durch 16
teilbar ist ich weiß da gibt es noch
andere optionen bei f3 wo man direkt die
dass man in einem schrank es aber damit
wird es quasi selber von minecraft auch
berechnet und das ist eigentlich
überhaupt nicht interessant
ich wusste schon alle freunde diese
sache wurde mir zugesendet von
österreicher 99 hielt richtig cooler
name und zwar wenn ich einen verbalen
trank der schnelligkeit werfe wir werden
einfach mal learning by doing machen und
2 werfen wert bei anfang der
schnelligkeit circa wenn ich hierhin
schaue denke ich so ein bisschen steht
kann ich den am weitesten werfen seht
ihr
der ist hier explodiert dass ich packe
mal eine sonderrolle einfach hin um zu
zeigen okay da er studiert ich kann zwar
noch mal probieren wenn ich mich hier so
hinstelle und ich werfe ihnen einfach
mal dahin seht ihr ja sogar noch einen
schritt weiter okay wir mal hier hin da
ist meiner explodiert wenn ich
allerdings einen merkbaren trank der
schnelligkeit beispielsweise mal in so
ein werfertag schaut euch mal an wie
weit er fliegt der flick einfach viel
viel weiter der es bis hierhin geflogen
das heißt wenn ich mal rein theoretisch
jetzt noch ein rein packe noch mal um zu
testen ob jetzt wirklich direkt dagegen
fliegt und zack ja er vielleicht
wirklich bis dahin wenn ich mich
allerdings hier hinstellen und hier mal
ein wegwerfe versuchen so weit wie
möglich kann ja auch mal springen und
ein bisschen schießen dann geht er
allerhöchstens bisher oder irgendwie
hier oder hier oder keine ahnung auf
jeden fall nicht so weit wie der hier
aus dem dispenser raus und er geht damit
so einer
krawumm macht raus also einen dispenser
kann doppelt so weit schützen wie ich
sie also passions doppelt so weit
schießen wie ich selber in minecraft das
hätte ich nicht gedacht ich hätte auch
nicht geglaubt dass das stimmt weil
sonst nutzt man ja dispenser immer und
drückt dann drauf natürlich pass direkt
in die fresse geworfen
aber ich meine wenn man sich das mal so
anschaut wie krass weiter das einfach
wegwirft sonne porschen das ist schon
krass wenn ich das mit mir vergleiche
sondern lappen der den einfach nur so
bis dahin werfen kann das ist schon ein
bisschen crazy dann kann dich ist doch
freunde der fünfte und letzte feld wurde
mit zuge von museum kraft und zwar
schreibt er dass man eine schere mit
einem schärfe buch verzaubern kann
allerdings nur eine richtung im amboss
und dann kann ich mit der auch anderem
ob schlagen und die wird nicht in der
haltbarkeit zurückgehen
also ich werde erstmal hier machen ich
setze den amboss in dem eine schere
er meinte nicht in die andere richtung
also wenn ich das so machen geht es
nicht das heißt wenn ich das so machen
geht es nur dann habe ich eine schere
mit affe 5 und jetzt werde ich mich
einfach mal in den game mode
null bewegen ich finde sie eigentlich
ein krasses das überhaupt funktioniert
jetzt schlage ich mal mit der schere auf
dieses jahr auf dieses pferd drauf ich
habe jetzt vier schläge gebraucht um das
schweren das um das pferd zu töten
jetzt nämlich einmal die schere die ganz
normale 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
17 18 19 ich brauche 19 schläge mit der
normalen schwere und vier mit der normal
mit dieser mit dieser schere mit schärfe
519 durch vier ist in etwa 5 es
funktioniert auf jeden fall und wenn wir
uns mal die dürre bildet die angucken
also die haltbarkeit von chase laden
hier dann ist das hier ist kein
haltbarkeit und hier ist es halt auch
nicht also hier ist halt normal ist halt
eine schere damit kann die geht halt
noch unter wenn ich damit irgendwie
leute schere schafe oder
etwas anderes kann ich ja gar nicht
scheren auf jeden fall funktioniert der
effekt man müsste sich das jetzt
natürlich anschauen ob ich die wirklich
jetzt bei 10 milliarden apps benutzen
kann und die geht nicht irgendwann
kaputt aber es ist auf jeden fall keine
kleinen leiste keine haltbarkeit leiste
angezeigt und deswegen ist es ein ganz
interessanter effekt das heißt
verwandelt auf jeden fall demnächst erst
mal eure schere obwohl eigentlich so ein
diamant schweren schiffen 5 ist noch ein
bisschen stärker ein bisschen viel
stärker aber das ist auf jeden fall eine
ganz gute alternative ist eine ganz
interessante sache
danke an die schmidts eli um treue
freunde und damit war's das auch schon
wieder mit der heutigen folge der
minecraft effekt wenn es euch gefallen
hat witze freundlich ist nur ein kleiner
clique da würde ich mich auf jeden fall
über den daumen hoch freuen wenn ihr
selber effekt kennt oder fisch oder so
schreibt in die kommentare in den
letzten sechs folgen fand ich die
textilien die kommentare in seine wurde
wurden entweder von irgendwem anders
geklaut oder waren einfach uninteressant
deswegen suche ich mit dem wiki oder
suche mir selber mal welche raus aber
wenn ihr richtig coolen wisst dann
schreibt man in die kommentare dann
sehen wir uns in dem anderen video
wieder tief